Цей документ – фінальне рішення
про ратифікацію Угоди про асоціацію ЄС та України.
Вітаю!
На підсумковій прес-конференції
після саміту ЄС-Україна у Києві
європейські гості Дональд Туск і Жан-Клод Юнкер підкреслено дружньо
спілкувалися з президентом України.
Однак вже вдруге цей саміт закінчився без підписання підсумкової декларації.
Київ прагнув, щоб у документі були слова
про визнання Євросоюзом європейських прагнень України.
Однак за наполяганням Нідерландів це формулювання
не внесли в документ. Тому вирішили
обійтися без декларації. У представництві ЄС в Україні
не бачать у цьому проблем.
Тут основне те, що записано в Угоді про асоціацію.
В преамбулі записано, що Європейський Союз визнає
європейські прагнення України і це є юридично зобов'язуючий текст,
так що тут є
таке підкреслення цих європейських амбіцій України.
І багато буде залежати від України,
як буде швидко втілювати цю угоду про асоціацію в життя,
бо ця угода як би є
такою дорожньою картою, яка може привести до членства.
Проте мовою дипломатії
другий саміт поспіль без підсумкового документа
є потужним сигналом для Києва. ЄС пішов
на впровадження безвізового режиму і схвалив угоду про асоціацію з Україною,
однак для подальшого зближення
у Брюсселі хочуть бачити результати реформ.
Президент Європейської Комісії Жан-Клод Юнкер
спочатку французькою, а потім англійською мовами
двічі повторив, що корупція –
одна з найбільших проблем України.
Про що ми просимо без читання лекцій для країни,
яка не потребує нотацій, -
це посилити боротьбу з корупцією, тому що
корупція підриває усі зусилля цієї великої нації.
Голова Єврокомісії  після завершення саміту
оголосив, що Європейський союз погодився на створення
антикорупційної палати в Україні в рамках Верховного суду
замість створення окремого антикорупційного суду,
як того вимагав ЄС.
Юнкер переконаний, що справа не в деталях організації інструментів боротьби,
а в реальному подоланні корупції.
Голова Єврокомісії наголосив, що інвестори не прийдуть в Україну,
доки не буде зруйновано корупцію на всіх щаблях.
Експерти говорять, що для просування реформ
тиску ззовні недостатньо.
Проблема подолання корупції залишається у фокусі
наших ключових міжнародних партнерів.
Але цей тиск зовнішній - він ефективний тільки тоді,
коли він підкіплюється тиском зсередини.
Зсередини - такий, як він був, наприклад, у 2014-му році.
Зараз цей тиск послабнув,
тому що відбулося
таке розшарування і фрагментація суспільних сил.
І це ж бачать самі корупціонери
і дуже ефективно цим користуються,
стравлюючи між собою різні суспільні групи.
Про зміни в Україні завдяки тиску суспільства,
підбиваючи підсумки саміту, нагадав і президент України.
А саме про те, що Угода про асоціацію з Євросоюзом
була однією з ключових вимог Євромайдану.
Нині керівництву країни треба ще втілити
те, що написано на папері.